hi
welcome back i'm really pleased to kick
off our next track
which is the dna hit of the year
presentation let me bring on stage tim
shalva president of gordon thomas
honeywell governmental affairs
who will present this year's dna hit of
the year tim take it away
well good morning it's a pleasure to be
back again giving the
dna hit of the year talk and it's also a
pleasure
to be with thermo fisher scientific's
hid conference the hits conference where
we give the hit of the year
results every year so thank you very
much and i look forward to a
a great presentation with you folks so
first of all let's keep in mind the
reasons
we do the hit of the year every year one
it's to recognize
not just the crime lab folks but also
law enforcement and everyone else in the
criminal justice system
including the policy makers that utilize
dna databases to solve and prevent crime
secondly we use this program as a way to
bring awareness
because we know that uh most of the
world still does not
have has not passed dna database
legislation or implemented these
programs so through real life cases
we can bring the awareness to the rest
of the world so they can also utilize
this great tool to solve crime
and we know when we bring this awareness
that it causes policy makers to take
action
not just on the legislation that allows
the offender database programs to exist
but also with the funding necessary to
implement these programs
so 2020 even with all that's going on in
the world we had 50 cases from
20 countries submit to the program from
those 50 cases
gordon thomas honeywell took the list
studied it
and recommended 17 cases to go
up to an international panel of seven
judges
the judges then reviewed those cases and
they ranked them
one through 17 independently we then
took the top six from their ranking
completed more research worked with the
judges to study the cases
and then the judges got on an
international conference call
and ranked the cases one through six
with the top cases
case being the one they selected as the
2020
hit of the year let's meet our judges
real quick
we have jody hines from orange county
california
walter parsons from innsbruck austria
ronaldo henane the crime lab director
from the philippines
magdalena the dna director from poland
mauricio hernandez the crime lab
director from costa rica
and christine sim the dna director
from singapore and also rock harmon a
retired prosecutor
from california usa so
with the 50 cases that were submitted
there were a lot of common themes this
year
uh some of the top ones were familial
searching
genetic genealogy missing persons
and ystr testing so what i'm going to do
for the remainder
of the presentation for about the next
40 so minutes
what we're going to explain is we're
going to look at the cases first
that were not selected in the top six
look at some of the common themes from
those cases
and then save the second half of the
presentation for the top six cases
where we will go into more detail about
each case
so let's kick it off we had uh the first
topic we wanted the common theme from
the cases
was the area of familial searching we
have a couple cases here
we also have a familial searching case
to discuss in our top six cases
but in this case in 1995 in a very uh
idyllic town on the coast of sweden in
billadel sweden
we had a rape of an eight-year-old girl
that it was attacked
on a bike ride home from her school she
was dragged in the woods sexually
assaulted
and then in a very injured she walked
back to her home this really shook this
little community
very small community and the the police
in sweden did an extensive investigation
they however the dna never matched like
many countries when the dna doesn't
match in the database they ponder
the idea of doing familial searching is
another step
however their law did not allow that so
they approached the
swedish parliament and
eventually they decided in late 2018 to
allow
sweden to be a country that does
familial searching they modeled their
law
on that of the united kingdom that has
done familial searching
very effectively over the years in a
very privacy conscious way
they have a national board that allows
them to that reviews the cases of which
ones get to be approved for
familial searching and then go all
through the privacy protections that are
necessary
to keep the the privacy issues in check
um when they were allowed to turn the
familial searching on when the law went
into effect on january 1 2019
this case was one of the top ones that
was approved by that board
and when as soon as they ran it they got
a candidate list
from the familial search and they were
able to investigate
and arrest the person that committed
this horrific crime
the next case relating to familial
searching
is a case coming to us from 2011 sexual
assault of a woman in dubai
and as you know from the case that dubai
selected submitted last year to hit of
the year that was i believe
chosen the second ranked case they go
very aggressively on dna approaches
and the same occurred in this case they
ran
the autosomal dna mat
to the database and there were no hits
they then did ystr
they did mido they did phenotypic snips
nothing worked and then they did
familial searching and
what they thought of doing in this case
what i thought was very unique
is that since they already did ystrs on
the casework sample
they decided to do a layer of ystr's on
the candidate list
produced by the familial search and
there was a match and that elevated it
to the top and they were able to solve
the case
pretty quickly with that so we thought
this was a very unique application of
why str is
uh integrating into familial searching
i'd like to say just a moment for meal
searching and wonder
if we're now at the tipping point of
countries and
states deciding to move forward with
familial searching
as we can see it works quite well when
you don't get a hit in your database
familial searching is a logical next
step
and it can be done effectively with a
lot of privacy controls as exemplified
uh in the united kingdom and now in
sweden and many other places as well so
i wonder
and i think that we are moving forward
to more countries looking at this
as an option as a second step to
searching when they don't get a match
in their database the next set of cases
i want to explain
we entitled the extremism murders and in
this first case
in 2019 there was a murder of a very
popular politician from the left side of
the political spectrum
that was very much disliked by the
extremist factions
in germany and he was assassinated in
his home
in hessen germany and unfortunately
there was no evidence at the crime scene
that could be noticed by the police but
fortunately they do have a wonderful
crime lab there
run by dr harold schneider
and they have a very unique process
there
that that lab and many others in germany
have developed and they call it hot
flaking
the idea is you take the clothes from
the person that you're looking for the
crime scene evidence from
and you take a piece of tape and you go
around each
inch of those clothes and you try to
extract skin flakes
and they did this over a thousand times
they found a thousand skin flakes
on the murdered politicians clothes and
one actual only one produced
a dna full profile and one would think
that would not likely be
a hit in the database but they got very
luckily lucky in this case a needle in a
haystack that one
profile they found through that hot
flaking process
mashed in the german dna database
and the person that hit to was a known
member of the neo-nazi party in germany
and therefore
is now the main suspect in this case
he's been arrested and i believe they're
in trial and this case is
just a testament to the hard work of the
german crime lab to
use that german-based system the hot
flaking process
to solve this case the second case i
want to mention of extremism murders is
the 2019
sexual assault and murder of a 19 year
old girl
walking through the woods in jerusalem
this case is really though
about speed in 24 hours from the moment
they found that body the crime lab was
able to get the dna
process it run it against the database
get a hit and the police were
able to arrest the suspect all within 24
hours and this is a testament
to israel's ability to fund a dna
program that allows them to move
that quickly to identify these
individuals and
israel has a very uh strong dna database
law that has a high hit rate which
allowed this case to be solved as well
unfortunately when they arrested this
individual he declared that he came into
jerusalem that night
to murder a jewish person therefore
showing the extremism
attentions of this killer
the next topic i want to talk about is
missing persons so in this
case in november of 1970
female remains were found in a house
fire in rural
minnesota united states later that month
an 18 year old girl at a university was
declared missing
it was 1970 they didn't have the systems
to link these two cases at the time
so the two mysteries went on
independently
fast forward to 2013 the brother
of the missing university's students
approached his parents who are now
in their 80s and he told them he said i
learned about the united states missing
persons program
and how you can have your dna as the
parents uploaded into it and then if it
matches
human remains we now are able to bring
our sis my sister home
they did that and unfortunately there
are no matches in our
estes database a couple years later 2016
a cold case team in the rural part of
minnesota decided to run the human
remains
in that house fire and when they did
that and they uploaded it to the
national database
there was a match and this these two
mysteries were solved at that moment
this is a great
end to this case but i have to bring up
the questions that a little bit
uh make us wonder whether or not we're
doing the right thing here
why did it take the brother of the
missing daughter of the
daughter to go to his parents and lobby
them and explain to them
about this process of giving your dna to
the united states national dna database
shouldn't we have a program in place
government entity
a program that promotes the missing
person's database so
everybody knows who's missing a loved
one in order that they're encouraged to
upload their dna
secondly 2016 is when they did the
remain testing but that body
has been dna has been available in the
missing persons program in the united
states since the 1990s so why did it
take so
long i think that we have a problem
again that we just do not promote our
missing persons program here in the
united states as much as it should be
and i know this problem is global as
well and to back this up in the united
states with some statistics
currently there are forty thousand
identified human remains
in our medical examiner's offices
throughout the united states
and only thirteen thousand of those
forty thousand have been tested
and uploaded to the national dna
database
furthermore with thinking about these 40
000 samples where
families are looking for them and then
hundreds of thousands of other
missing persons where there's no human
remains we only have
15 000 families that have uploaded their
dna
to endis that tells me that we simply do
not have the legal infrastructure
the funding and the motivation for
people to take advantage of this program
to identify
human remains i think it's time in the
united states that we focus on this and
that we have some sort of national
institute that brings all that together
that allows this to happen routinely
and could be a model for the other
countries as well
another missing person's case comes to
us being solved by genetic genealogy
so in idaho united states this case
1979 mummified human remains that had
been dismembered and chopped up were
found in a lava tube
in rural idaho they take that dna
and they compare it to the national
database and there were no matches
they then decided in 2019 to apply
genetic genealogy
to that case and they got a hit to jet
match and after 2
000 hours it led them to an 87 year old
grandson
of these human remains and when they
interviewed this person
this grandson he had quite the tale to
tell
he said yes my grandfather was not a
good person
he apparently murdered my grandmother
with an axe
and the sheriff declared that he was
looking for him for murder
he also told another tale that the town
folks
in that town put together a vigilante
squad
vigilante squad and they went out and
tracked him down and murdered him and
then he said that this genealogy test
now confirmed that rumor
so now we're going to move over to the
issue of dna databases and exonerations
this these cases were submitted the
first time they submit
i'm listing two however for the sake of
time i'm only going to mention the first
one
so 1976 the sexual assault of murder of
a 15 year old girl
in flint united kingdom the police
developed two suspects in this case
one was an 18 year old boy who didn't
speak english
that was a transient and that's his
picture today on the right
he was interrogated very aggressively by
the police and confessed to a crime
that he did not commit and spent 20
years in prison
the second suspect they interviewed they
did not have enough evidence
and they didn't convict him so fast
forward
to current day the police in the united
kingdom decided to reopen this case to
go after
the second suspect and see if the dna
found with this girl is a match to the
second suspect
and when they did the test they found
three things
one that second suspect was not a match
uh to the dna that was found at the
crime scene
secondly it didn't match the person that
spent 20 years behind bars so he got
exonerated and the suspect got
exonerated as well
so this is a great result to get both of
those exonerated but in addition to that
they found the true perpetrator because
he was in the united kingdom database
when they ran that dna
and if just a reminder for those that
don't know the united kingdom has
probably the highest dna hit rate in the
world because they require
everybody convicted and arrested to go
into the database for a period of time
their hit rate hovers around somewhere
between 60
and 70 percent and that's the type of
result you can get when you have that
large of a database policy
in your laws so this case in the case
beneath it are good examples of getting
people
that are in jail or have been in jail
released and exonerated
through the use of dna but more
importantly i believe
the exonerations that happen not just in
these types of cases
every once in a while it's the
exoneration that
happens due to dna databases probably on
an
hourly basis throughout this world
when police have these databases and hit
on the right person quickly
they do not investigate somebody that is
innocent they do not knock on the door
and ask them that they were if they were
involved in a serious crime
crime like a homicide and make that
adrenaline go up in that individual
and be worried until they're cleared
because they find the right person with
the database
they don't have to make these people
feel uncomfortable through those types
of
interrogations and that is how dna
databases
exonerate people daily throughout this
world
so just to mention a couple other cases
here we're not going to go through all
these but
uh wanted to mention at least two and
the first one comes to us from poland we
call it the power of proof in poland so
for a 20-year period there were stranger
rapes occurring in
czech republic germany and poland then
then the
polish police arrested and convicted
somebody they went into the database and
it hit to the rape in poland
and because of the forward thinking of
the european union with the proved
treaty
it also hits those rapes in germany
and czech republic this next case we
call
criminals aren't always smart and in
this case
an individual staked out a jewelry heist
in the united kingdom
and he noticed that that jewelry store
did not have a cctv camera
hooked up so he did a tunnel underneath
the store and unfortunately for him
he made the wrong decision he went the
wrong way in the tunnel and went into
another shop
and when he pulled himself through the
tunnel he touched and that shop did have
a cctv camera and it saw exactly where
he touched the police swab right there
they got dna went into the database and
of course
it's the united kingdom so they got a
match and that's how that case got
solved
so we're now going to move over to the
top
six cases and again the judges went
through
and ranked those cases and here are the
six that they
they they voted on in the end and they
ranked them one through six
and the cases they they ranked were from
washington state
usa california usa brazil
another california usa case france
and china and we will talk about them in
the order in which the judges place them
the first the first one the sixth place
case is the murder
of jane hilton and the exoneration of
ricky davis occurring in el dorado hills
california and for those of you don't
know el dorado hills
is basically a suburb of the city of
sacramento in northern california
so in 1985 jane hilton
was murdered in her home she was stabbed
multiple times
she was bitten in the back and the
police came and there were three
people that lived with her they talked
to them but there was no other evidence
and the case goes cold they reopened the
case
in 1999 and they completed an
interrogation of those three individuals
that was the focus of their
investigation
and they focused on connie dahl and
interrogated her
and explained to her that the woman was
bitten in the back and
offered her some sort of immunity and
she therefore said ricky davis was the
one who did it
he stabbed her i only held her down and
bit her in the back
and with that immunity um that was the
testimony
that she gave and ricky davis was
convicted
this didn't sit well of course the ricky
davis always maintained his innocence
and the innocence project didn't like
the status of that interrogation and
that confession of
of uh connie dahl so they took on the
case in addition
they did not take dna in that case so
this innocence project actually focused
with
the sacramento county crime lab
and the prosecutor the new generation of
prosecutor in this case
uh uh was very uncomfortable with it to
begin with two so he cooperated
and they they focused on the dna from
the night gown on the spot
where the woman said she bit right
and if they could show that the dna on
that nightgown
didn't match connie dahl they could
discredit her testimony and it would be
a
an ability to show that ricky davis did
not commit this crime
sure enough the dna did not match but
because they
didn't match to anybody in the database
they couldn't show who committed the
crime
they had to delay him getting out of
prison but they did offer him a new
trial but they didn't want to wait for
the trial to be over to get ricky davis
out of jail
so they decided to pursue genetic
genealogy and sure enough
they got a match to jet match did the
genealogical research
and they hit to this individual
in fact the gen match uh occurred
in uh december of 2019
but the actual uh hit and the
the research the gen the genealogy
research that took place
just a few months ago and this is the
person that actually committed the crime
and now that they know who committed the
crime they allowed ricky davis to walk
out of prison on february 13
2020. the fifth place case
is the 1991 sexual assault and murder of
sarah yarbow
and the town of federal way which is a
suburb of seattle washington which is
actually
just up the street from where i'm coming
from you today as i
live in the seattle area so in 1991
uh this 16 year old girl that had a lot
going for her
was murdered on her school grounds and
you can imagine the traumatic
um she was sexually assaulted too the
traumatic
event of that for having her body found
by other students
and just the impact on a school like
that
they had dna from the crime scene but it
never
matched encoders interesting piece about
this case
they actually were the first case to
ever do ystr surname searching
and when they did that they hit to the
fuller family
and they thought they had solved this
case because there was a close friend
that was named fuller that was a friend
of the yarborough family
and however upon the autosomal testing
it wasn't him
they tried to go up the relationship
path and identify of other fullers
however the real suspect in this case
his grandfather about 67 years ago fell
out of the fuller family because he was
adopted so it was a dead end trail
so then in 2019 they did genetic
genealogy and it led them to this
individual and this case has been solved
um i do want to mention though some
things about the database law here in
washington state
uh that controls the database of
offenders
in this region they had three missed
opportunities
and it's just a reminder that the laws
that are passed by your parliaments
or your state legislatures in this case
control
how quickly you can solve a crime and
how long these individuals would be on
the streets perhaps committing more
crime
so in this this case the three misses
that they had based on our faulty laws
one
this individual was convicted of a sex
crime before he murdered sarah
and therefore if the washington state
law would have required parolees to be
in the database
they could have taken his dna and after
he committed the murder they would have
found him right away
secondly this individual was arrested
for a sex crime
but then pled to a lower level sex crime
and the washington state legislature
did not have that sex crime in the
database policy
when that occurred and therefore they
missed them a second time and finally
this guy's brother was a convicted
rapist that was also
in the washington state database and
because washington state
government does not allow familial
searching we missed them a third time
so just a reminder the policies made by
the politicians
are the they decide who gets identified
for these terrible crimes
and we should look at all of our laws to
determine whether or not they're set up
in a way
that can keep people like this off the
street
so just to comment about we've had these
couple of cases in genetic genealogy
we had of course the big cases last year
and the golden state killer
and the very many other cases as well
what's the future
of genetic genealogy in forensics
and i look at ged match and the other
databases that allow police
to catch these criminals is kind of like
a magic portal
and when it first happened last year and
we saw these cases coming through
i couldn't believe it it was basically
it changed everything the way we think
about solving crime
with dna and it did a lot of work and
these are just some of the individuals
these
cases in the united states that had
never going to be solved that now
because of this magic portal are going
to be solved
um i think where we're headed is that
genetic genealogy we've kind of worked
through the backlog of the old cases
that would never be solved
and from now on i think we're going to
see what we'll call a plan b
approach on every new case so if you
have a homicide
a stranger rape other types of assaults
that can't be solved when you
put the dna into the codis database you
go to plan b
which is genetic genealogy and i think
that's just going to integrate itself in
a normal law enforcement practice
and we'll see that plan b on all cases
going for all serious cases
going forward
so the fourth place case is the 2008
murder
of a mom and her daughter in guangzhou
china in fact
it was in a very upscale neighborhood in
their high-rise condo where somebody
broke in to commit a property crime
ran into them killed both of them and
left
a single drop of blood behind at the
crime scene
now they took that dna and they put it
into the massive
chinese database as you may know china
has
50 000 criminal offenders or excuse me
50 million
criminal offenders in their database the
largest dna database in the world by far
and again if you don't solve them with
an autosomal hit in that database
china is eventually going to find the
killer because in addition to those
autosomal 50 million database they also
have 10 million folks
that are in the ystr database so again
between the two they're eventually going
to get a leak
and that happened in this case because
in 2019 there was a ystr match between
somebody named
june who's an only child to the killer's
ysdr
they tried the autosomals against june
and if there was no match
so like any good ystr investigation what
do you do next
you go check the father and the father's
brothers and they did that
and there was no autosomal match but a
curious thing happened they noticed
through kinship testing that the father
and the five uncles were all half
siblings to june
and the killer so this got the
investigators thinking
and they kind of figured it out and they
went and got the dna from
june's grandfather and june's mother and
it turns out they produced
a secret child that they put up for
adoption so the police went out
investigated the adoption records it led
them to the true killer that they lured
back to guangzhou
and hear the police are arresting him at
the guangzhou airport so this case very
amazing case a lot of work obviously
went into solving this case the third
place case
is a case that came from woodland
california usa
and in 2017 in woodland california
is also by the way it's a suburb of the
san francisco area
and in 2007 excuse me
the remains of an infant boy were found
in a metal chest and brought up
somebody fishing in a canal and the boy
had been murdered clearly but because of
blunt
force trauma to his skull and they took
the dna
and put in the missing person's database
but there were no matches
in 2018 the sheriff the prosecutor and
the state police
decided they're going to try familial
searching of the human remains
against the offender database in
california
however there is not a process to search
human remains in california familial
searching although there is one
for searching crime scene samples
against
convicted offenders um but they got
permission to do this and when they did
they hit to the infant's father that
also was actually just three days from
being released from prison
and then we asked they asked him to
identify the child
he wouldn't do it so the investigators
then went and researched all the
children
that he had been recorded as being the
father of in california
and they got the the genetic testing
card from the hospital
and the first case that i'm aware of
they got a court order to take the dna
off the card and compare it to the human
remains where they determined that this
boy
his name is nico and they were able to
determine that
from the the genetic cards that were
maintained at the hospital
but very disturbing about this case
during the research they also determined
that were four other
infants that have not been heard of
since they were born
and so as a result of that uh this
county has charged this individual for
five
counts of murder a serial emphasized
case that's going on
currently and we're going to hear a lot
more about this case as it plays out in
the court
so that leaves us with two finalist
cases
we have the cases from brazil
and the case from france so the judges
voted
and they determined that the 2020 hit of
the year
is the case from brazil and so before i
outline that case and also we're
fortunate after i speak we're going to
hear for a few minutes from the crime
lab and investigators from the brazilian
federal police
about the case but before i do that i
want to talk to you about the french
case
so this case it's called the little
martyr of the a10 motorway
in blue is france so this
this little child that you see here in
the picture she was about four years old
was abused and abandoned and thrown in
this ditch where the police officer
is pointing she was clearly abused for
the following reasons one
they found that she had broken bones
that had healed and
re-injured over time um she had human
bite marks on her body
she had marks from an iron where she had
been scorched and she had been very
malnourished
so this case became a very important
case the people of france
apparently it was the most investigated
case for about 15 or 20 years
they really wanted to know who she was
and where she came from
the dna story goes like this in this
case
1993 when dna got its legs
they resumed the body took the dna from
the remains tested it against the
databases and there is no match
in 2008 they decided to do phenotypic
snips and you can imagine this was
before next generation so it meant that
the thermo fisher scientific 3130 device
was chugging away over time and
eventually
cranked out the right snips to determine
that they were from
north american ancestry
then in 2013 dna technology took another
leap forward and they were able to do
more touch dna
and as a result of that they were able
to fi find a full sibling
dna on the the deceased child's blanket
and because the french policy allows
them to upload those types of samples to
their database that
probably not from the killer because it
was a young child's dna
into the database this proved to be
the perfect solution of this case
because in 2017
the sibling was convicted of
a crime in france and went into the
french offender database
and therefore matched to the dna that
that person left
on the blanket and as a result of that
they were able to research this case
find the mother
and she has been charged and arrested
for neglect
and murder so that leads us to the 2020
head of the year which is called by the
media
in brazil and throughout the world
actually is the robbery of the century
and the reason it's called the robbery
of the century
because it's a blockbuster case as
you'll see it
it feels like it's a movie script and it
was committed by the largest
criminal organization in brazil
the crime actually occurred in ciudad
del este
which is in paraguay and for those of
you who have not heard of this town it's
the second largest city in paraguay it's
actually
on the border a river separates it from
brazil
and argentina and it is known to mean
the community close
to the the beautiful iguesu falls
that is apparently the largest
waterfalls in the world
so it is as i mentioned it was committed
by the largest criminal organization
in brazil it is known as the pcc
it has 20 000 members it's active in 22
of the 27 brazilian states as well as
other
south american countries it focuses on
drug trafficking big time robberies like
this one
and other illicit activities they rule
over the famous
favelas in brazil and as one of our
judges on our panel this year said
that's from the region
unfortunately strong criminal
organizations
are part of our life in central and
south america
so this was the crime scene this is what
occurred april 24th
2017 the target was 40 million u.s
dollars
that was stashed inside of the
progressors
cash transit facility's office in this
town
and over 50 heavily armed assailants
prepared at a staging house in paraguay
they then crossed into paraguay in a
military-style raid
they blew up the building they grabbed
the vaults
took as much money as they could and
then created a path of destruction as
they worked their way back into brazil
that ended with a three-hour shootout
with the brazilian federal police
so here are the crime scenes in the case
we had
uh we have the paraguay staging house
where the 50 people uh staged the crime
we have the
bomb blast of the presager site and we
had the shootout
with the brazilian police from those
three crime scenes the brazilian federal
police collected
457 pieces of evidence and from that
they had touched dna from abandoned
escape boats and vehicles they had dna
throughout the staging house on
bedding on plates things like this they
had dna from weapons and explosives
left at the at the the bomb sites and
they had blood from the bullet wounds
from the shootout with the police they
also had
three suspects that died in the shootout
they had their dna that got
uploaded and they had seven suspects
that got captured at the shootout they
had their dna
and it got uploaded so in the end the
brazilian brazilian federal police crime
lab were able to find
from these 457 pieces of evidence
47 full profiles that they put into
their database in addition
11 suspects that also went into the
database and just gave you a little bit
of background about the brazilian coda
system
it's the second largest installation of
codis behind the united states
they have 20 state network that upload
to a national
dna database the brazil federal police
but the dna database in brazil is quite
new in fact
it just started to move forward just a
couple years ago because of a decision
by the
government of brazil to make dna testing
in its database the top priority
to fight crime in brazil but since it's
just started it only has
70 000 criminals in the database however
we predict in the next five years brazil
will probably be one of the top five
databases
size wise in the world
so the 47 crime scene samples and 11
vendors got uploaded in the database and
here were the hits that occurred as a
result of that
first 9 and 11 suspect matched to the
crime scene so that from the shootout
they were able to because they met they
took the dna they met they compared it
to the
found at the staging house and at the
bomb blast and therefore
they were able to place these suspects
at that crime scene
secondly 14 of the 47 crime scene
profiles
linked to other serious crimes and there
were big serious crimes that were
conducted by this gang
just a couple of examples there was a
murder of a federal agent that it linked
to
another one was a 28 million similar
heist of a brink's car company
uh facility and in addition to that
as i mentioned excuse me in addition to
that
there were matches to offenders however
because this is a new database
there's only 70 000 people in it you
weren't going to have a lot of hits of
these 47
profiles in the beginning it's about the
future in this case
and that's exactly what happened there
wasn't any instant matches
to offenders in the database when they
put these 47 in they came later and
they'll continue to come
and this is exactly what happened in
june of 18
one of the people at the crime scene
matched when they got convicted and put
in the database
it happened again in march of 19 again
in july of 19
again in march of just a couple months
ago march of 2020
so again this is about the future with
this case
um they have 13 identifications so far
there's 34 to go and because of the
investment
by the brazilian government to build
this database our guests
is that most of these 47 people that
were at those crime scenes
are going to hit the database over time
so i think the judges in this case they
voted it number one
for a number of reasons first of all the
blockbuster nature of it
and secondly the hard work of the
brazilian police crime lab i mean they
have 400 plus
samples they had to work through uh and
under very difficult circumstances was
amazing work
third is we talked about the future of
the dna database program in brazil and
the recognition of the government to
make it a strong program
and finally what dna can do to take a
bite out of these criminal organizations
so those four things combined
are the reason they ranked it uh the
number one case
so before we hand it over to our friends
in brazil
uh that were selected as the number one
case
i do want to make some acknowledgments
of course everybody from the brazil
federal police
secondly is our dna hit of the year
judges they did a wonderful job
reviewing these cases we know it's a lot
of work so thank you very much judges
and kyle schroeder and hannah jones from
gordon thomas honeywell did a lot of
work as well
to put this program together this year
and finally thermo fisher scientific
thank you so much you folks sponsor this
program every year we couldn't do
it without you and thank you for
allowing us to explain these cases and
the selection by the judges
at your annual kids conference so with
that
i'll hand it over to the brazil folks
thank you very much
the robbery of the century a big
case the biggest one in the forensic dna
lab
of the brazilian federal police and now
it is the dna hit of the year 2020.
this is so important to us and it was
such an honor working on this case
gathering all the data and having the
opportunity to show it to you
that's english because i want to address
directly to first chin shelburne
in behalf of whole night thank the
gordon thomas hanwell group
for sponsoring the dna heat of the year
program
thank you kyle schroeder for your
patience and real
interest in understanding all the
details of this case
with so many profiles crime scenes
links i know it was a little bit tricky
sometimes
i want to thank all the judges for
recognizing our hard work on this case
we are so many involved federal and
states
forensic dna experts csi experts and
criminal investigators
this award is a big push for us to keep
going and growing proudly
and thanks tamara fisher for always
being a partner
in heaven's ears here at his virtual
conference
system contributing
foreign
is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
great i think we're we're back on
great so everybody thank you again for
taking the time to listen to this year's
dna hit of the year presentation
i just wanted to because we weren't able
to list the names of the three brazilian
folks that presented at the end i wanted
to give you
uh their information the first person
that spoke her name is anna de castro
she is a senior forensic scientist in
the brazil federal police
the second speaker was ronaldo de silva
he is the national dna
database custodian and the final speaker
was emerson rodriguez
who is the head of investigations for
this case for the brazilian federal
police obviously you could tell by their
excitement
uh they're important it was in this for
people to work on this case throughout
the federal police organization in
brazil
so with that everybody i know it's been
a uh a a
great morning for you for your
conference and i'll hand it back to be
and i just appreciate
being able to present the dna hit of the
year and we'll see you next year thank
you
be
be a uh just it sounds like you're muted
b just so you're aware
uh your computer must be on mute
yes tim thank you i was on you
sorry guys okay
thank you i was on youtube thank you tim
um
i was saying anyway thank you to
everyone that did submit their cases to
share with us because
um it really gives us hope that no
matter how heinous the crime is whether
it's big crime or a small crime
or how long ago it took place someone is
still looking into it
and as technology evolves and countries
expand and establish the database
there is more hope that these cases will
still get close as time goes on so
that's really hopeful
so thank you tim and at this time we'll
take a 25 minute break
to give you a chance to see the
conference the exhibition courses and
application halls
and we'll see you back here at 12 30
singapore time
1 30 japan korea time and 2 30
australian
standard time thank you bye
bye